MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture
and also the next one,
we'll look at some of
the experimental findings
of neutrinos.
Given the sheer
number of experiments
and the long history
in which we are
trying to understand neutrinos
and neutrinos' behavior,
this can be rather confusing.
So I'm trying to condense
this a little bit
and just give you the
highlights, or the basic pieces
of information.
So this one here shows
a summary of what we
know from neutrino oscillation.
So if we look at
atmospheric neutrinos,
we find that mirror neutrinos
and anti-mirror neutrinos
disappear, and
they're most likely
converting into tau neutrinos
and anti-tau neutrinos.
We look at accelerating
neutrinos-- here
we are using mirror
neutrinos and anti-mirror
ones-- we can show that they
disappear over distances
of 200 to 800 kilometers.
From accelerators, we also know
that they appear or reappear
as electron or
anti-electron neutrinos
over those same distances.
From the solar
neutrinos, we know
that electron neutrinos
convert into mirror neutrinos
and/or tau neutrinos.
There is more
detail to this story
than I'm giving
you here, where we
would have to discuss the
interaction of the matter
effects of neutrinos.
That is for a different lecture.
That goes beyond the scope of
what I want to discuss here.
From reactor
neutrinos, we also know
that anti-electron
neutrinos disappear as well.
So the name of the
game now is to take
all of those pieces
of information
and extract information about
the neutrinos' property.
And in order to do that,
one has to make assumption
about the number of available
neutrino generations,
and in some part of
the interpretation,
also about the nature
of the neutrinos.
As you can simply figure out
of the exercise we had before,
it matters to the neutrino
oscillation probabilities
whether one assumes two or three
or four neutrinos in the mix.
But if you just focus
here on three neutrinos,
you still have the
problem that we have
degeneracies in the discussion.
And they can be boiled down
to two major kind of trends.
One is where the spectrum
of the neutrino mass
follows a normal
ordering, meaning
that the mass of
the first is smaller
than the mass of the
second is smaller
than the mass of the third, or
that the spectrum is inverted,
meaning that the mass of
the third might be smaller
than the mass of the
second and the mass of--
the first and the second.
Data suggests that
the difference squared
in mass splittings
between those states
is such that delta
m12 squared is
much smaller than delta
m31 squared, which
is approximately the same
size as delta m32 squared.
So if you look
now at the numbers
for the normal
hierarchy spectrum,
we find that the mass of the
first is much, much smaller
than the mass of the second,
which is a little bit smaller
than the mass of the third.
Numerically, we find
the mass of the second
is in the order of 8 times 10
to the minus 3 electron-volt,
and the mass of the third in the
order of 0.05 electron-volts,
so really, really small masses.
The inverted spectrum-- here
the story is slightly different.
Here we find that m1 is about
0.05 election-volts, which
is similar to the square root
of the mass splitting between 3
and 2, which is also
0.05 electron-volts.
The information of the neutrino
oscillation experiment,
and then how to map into
the individual parameters
of our neutrino CKM matrix
is summarized here, and also
in the mass information.
And I don't want to
read the entire table.
I'll just leave
this here for you.
So in order to
understand this, one
has to go back to
the first slide
and understand what
kind of information
we extract from various neutrino
experiments-- for example,
the solar neutrino experiments--
and then think about,
is this sensitive
to oscillations
between the first and
the second generation,
or the first and the
third generation?
So that's kind of the mapping
you have to do in order
to understand this table fully.
There are some experiment
where the information just
dominates the position
of a certain measurement.
In others, there is combinations
of results coming out.
The other reason why I put
this table here in this lecture
is to just illustrate
how diverse the landscape
of experiments is and
why that's needed.
In order to get a full
picture of neutrinos
and their properties,
one has to identify
the individual properties
in the experiments
and then put the picture
back together in a global fit
or in a general
analysis of the data.